[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le grand studio
du figaro on est en direct on est avec
vous c'est figaro live et on attend vos
points de vue que doit faire emmanuel
macron face à l'évolution de la crise
sanitaire attentes durcir assouplir et
bien avant débat de ce soir et on va en
débattre également avec jérôme jaffré
bonsoir je rouvre soir on va dire vous
êtes politologue et directeur du cecop
et bien d'autres qualités que bien sûr
les internautes ne vont pas découvrir
parce qu'il vous connaissent déjà mais
qu'ils vont pouvoir redécouvrir ensemble
ce soir et avec vous avec nous alexis
brézet directeur des rédactions du
figaro on se voit maintenant soir alexis
et le figaro qui a recueilli la réaction
de nicolas sarkozy 24 heures après sa
condamnation interview à découvrir dans
les prochaines heures sur le site du
figaro et bien sûr dans l'édition papier
datée de demain et c'est par là qu'on
commencera ce soir la carrière de
nicolas sarkozy est elle finie
définitivement fini c'est d'ailleurs la
question qu'on vous pose sur twitter à
ce que vous parce que vous pensez en
tous les cas pour l'instant vous êtes
partagés un léger avantage pour le oui
53% mais ce n'est pas la vie par exemple
de marine le pen qui se fend même d'un
conseil à l'ancien président à l'ancien
adversaire
je ne souhaite pas que les magistrats
face la primaire de la présidentielle
mais lorsque j'ai envie que les
magistrats détermine qui seront mes
adversaires à y renoncer
et je vais même plus loin je vais vous
dire je pense que nicolas sarkozy compte
tenu de la jurisprudence fillon si
nicolas sarkozy souhaite être candidat à
la présidentielle
eh bien il doit l'être il devrait l'être
malgré la condamnation dont je rappelle
qu'elle n'est pas définitive
malgré la condamnation qui a été
prononcée longuet alors chez les
républicains
l'actuel président christian jacob lui
est plus plus prudent plus mesuré on
écoute il vient d'avoir un juge
mans avec une condamnation qui est
inexplicable qui est totalement
disproportionnée et les sujets
politiques viendront plus tard mais ça
n'est en tout cas pas le moment nous
nous concentrons sur les élections sur
deux choses les élections
départementales et les élections
régionales
viendra le temps des présidentielles on
en parlera mais c'est pour plus tard
alexis est ce que c'est terminé pour
sarkozy est ce qui d'ailleurs il l'a
fait dès qu on fait ce qu'on peut dire
c'est maintenant s'il a fait des
confidences ou pas sur ce sujet dans
l'interview donc du figaro qu'on va
mettre en ligne bientôt c'est un peu tôt
pour le dire j'ai pas le texte alors
donc créé ce qui s'est passé de nos
journalistes stéphane durand souffland
et notre chroniqueur judiciaire marion
mourgue qui la jeunesse qui suit la
droite sont tous ont vu nicolas sarkozy
ce matin
donc on n'a pas le texte définitif ils
sont en train de travailler dessus en
fin d'après ce que je sais ce qu'ils
m'ont dit c'est que d'abord sur la
tonalité l'italie c'est une grande
détermination à côté offensif pas non
plus de filippi contre la justice pas de
procès ce général à la justice une
contestation vigoureuse du jugement qui
le juge
au fond il a le sentiment d'être
condamné pour des choses qui n'a pas
fait et donc il le dit il le répète il
dit je me battrai jusqu'au bout le
jusqu'à la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme s'il le faut mais pas pas un
procès général intenté à la justice pour
le que sur la tonalité et pour l'action
de la politique dont vous parliez
d'après ce que ce qu'il a dit mais là
encore il faut quand même attendre
maintenant la version définitive
l'idée c'est de dire au fond j'avais dit
que je tourner la page de la politique
n'y a pas de raison que ce qui ce se
sait pas c est avec ce jugement change
m'a dit maman mon intention tourner la
page ne veut pas dire ne pas avoir un
avis sans doute donnera-t-il son avis et
sans doute c'est là toute la nuance de
de la vie c'est pas blanc noir s'est pas
excusée dans la politique et ce qui
déborde la politique c'est de quelle
manière va t-il rester dans la politique
et comment vont-ils faire exercer son
influence d'un petit parce que de votre
choix est là de quelle manière va t-il
rester dans la politique de quelle
manière peut-il rester au regard de
l'évolution de l'eau
l'union dans la politique de réaction
peut-être d'internautes avant d'avoir la
vôtre jérôme cet internaute qui dit sa
carrière est finie depuis 2017 et sa
cuisante défaite aux primaires qui
remonte à 2016 d'ailleurs et on à kriss
kross par exemple qui me dit mon coeur
d'homme de droite saigne depuis la
condamnation de nicolas sarkozy hier
oui c'est cette une déflagration
politique c'est quelque chose de tout à
fait considérable ça va toucher
évidemment les relations des français
aux institutions il faut pas se cacher
que un président de la république
un ancien président de la république
toujours aussi présent dans la vie du
pays qui est condamné à la prison ferme
dans une affaire de corruption c'est un
bouleversement et donc c'est même si
vous voulez du coup c'est l'image de la
politique qui profondément atteinte à
travers ça et pour une partie des
français l'image de la justice aussi car
il ya beaucoup de choses qu'on ne
comprend pas bien dans cette affaire
mais je reviens pas là dessus
la droite est profondément touché alors
christian jacob évacue va s'occuper des
départementales et des régionales très
bien c'est évidemment important pour
tous ceux qui se représente au sein de
la droite
mais voyez tous les leaders de la droite
sont atteints depuis 20 ans par des
affaires judiciaires
excusez moi dans les livres d'histoire
ce sera quelque chose de considérable
1 nous avons chirac
peut-être balladur demain nous avons
juppé nous avons fillon nous avons
maintenant sarkozy excusez du peu
ceux qui ont été présidents ceux qui
sont était premier ministre sont
atteints par des affaires judiciaires et
des condamnations judiciaires pour la
plupart d'entre eux donc c'est une
déflagration pour la droite française
qui peut avoir des conséquences
considérables sur la présidentielle de
2000 22 j'imagine qu'on y reviendra
pour nicolas sarkozy lui même s'est
évidemment
un choc considérable parce que nicolas
sarkozy bon il disait qu'il avait
abandonné la politique évidemment il ne
l'avait jamais abandonner s'il y avait
une fenêtre un soupirail pour pouvoir
aller à la présidentielle il se serait
glissé dedans évidemment il savait bien
que c'était depuis la défaite de la
primaire de 2016 que votre internaute
rappeler très finement
il savait que cette voie là était
extrêmement difficile maintenant le
problème de sarkozy ça va être sa
réhabilitation
l'interview du figaro qui paraîtra
demain nous donnera déjà des signaux de
comment ils pensent le faire mais quand
je parle des livres d'histoire pour
nicolas sarkozy c'est déjà l'enjeu
immédiat c'est quel regard on porte et
on portera sur nicolas sarkozy
et puis sarkozy y penser un peu être le
maître du jeu de la présidentielle de
2000 22 non pas pour être candidat lui
même mais pour faire le président de
c'était ça qui l'avait est-ce qu'il va
garder cette capacité je je je je laisse
la réponse en suspens pour ne pas être
interminable aux pauvres la vie d'alexis
sur la question cet internaute encore
qu'il dit mais toute la droite et
ressouder finalement depuis depuis hier
depuis cette condamnation est cet autre
internaute dit mais c'est le grand
conseiller de macron il travaille encore
alors deux choses tout la doite
réconcilier de ressouder derrière
sarkozy puisque c'est vrai que toutes
les déclarations des déclarations de
soutien à nicolas sarkozy on peut pas
exclure
et ça rejoint ce que dit jérôme une
certaine une certaine dose de sincérité
on peut jamais exclure absolument qaîda
siders que des hommes politiques
et c'est vrai que c'est un choc c'est un
traumatisme
certains les mêmes dont on ne l'aimé pas
mais ils avaient tous
pris l'habitude de vivre avec l'ombre
tutélaire depuis de faire leurs calculs
en fonction de ce que va faire sarkozy
que va dire sarkozy et tout à coup
sarkozy frappé par cette sanction qui
lui tombe sur la foudre mais dessus
comme le foot mais que leur tombre un
peu tout ça tous dessus
donc ils sont d'autant plus en empathie
avec sarkozy qu'au fond ils subissent un
peu ce contre ce coup du sort bon après
il ya aussi un peu des larmes de
crocodile et la caricature et en marine
le pen qui n'a jamais vu ça aussi ça
reconnaît depuis qu'elle sait que
sarkozy est donc il ya un peu une course
à récupérons les électeurs de rikers
sarkozy récupère ont peut-être l'onction
pour l'avenir de nicolas sarkozy
montrons que nous sommes généreux en
plaignant nicolas sarkozy puisque il est
dans la peine
ça aussi ça fait partie de 2,2 du jeu
politique donc la grande la droite
absolument qu'est ce que vous disiez
c'est quoi ces ressources ou de lait
elle l'était pas avant elle le sera pas
davantage après c'est des blacks ce qui
est vrai c'est qu'elle n'était pas très
bien avant qu'elle ait pas très bien
après ça c'était la première question de
la deuxième question c'est est premier
et deuxième question c'était son rôle
auprès de auprès d'emmanuel macro ont
finalement c'est ce que leur vie cet
autre ça c'est un vrai mystère
c'est vrai que dans la façon dont il
nicolas sarkozy
imaginez s'enroule d'après les
confidences qui avaient pu faire aux uns
et aux autres
avant c'était avant ce jugement on
voyait bien qu'il y avait plusieurs
options que parmi ces options il y avait
une option qu'on peut jamais tout à fait
écartée qui était celle de revenir lui
c'était ça reste tu es dans une partie
de sa tête il reste peut-être encore
d'une partie de l'idée de après tout
j'ai été victime d'une injustice les
français m'ont mal jugé la défaite
la défaite aux primaires qui et c'est
vrai pour lui sans doute la plus grave
et la plus humiliante et donc il y avait
cette partie là mais qui était quand
même pas le plan principal qui était pas
le plan du retour il aurait fallu
vraiment que les choses aillent très
très très très mal pour macron pour pour
le pour imaginer que puisse revenir mais
ça faisait partie quand même des choses
envisageable et puis ensuite il y avait
pesé sur la présidentielle soit en
adoubant un candidat de droite
à condition que rien qui soit bien placé
et on sentait bien que c'était quand
même pas sa tante sa sa tentation
comment dire la plus naturelle au fond
on n'aime jamais trop couronné quelqu'un
de son propre camp on n'est jamais
absolument mais mécontent quand on se
rend compte qu'il ya personne pour vous
remplacer et donc l'autre option c'est
de se dire je serai je suis celui qui
finalement pourrait ramener une partie
la droite où une partie de la droite à
emmanuel macron celui qui au moment où
il faudra choisir aurait dû dire mon
écoute et maintenant il sait où marine
le pen au minium macron à tout prendre
et puis après tout il sait pas si mal
débrouillé d'ailleurs on remarquera que
dans toute la sphère du cou où il
présente il voit sarkozy était d'une
grande modération et n'a jamais critiqué
l'exécutif
je fais attention à ménager mâcon
question est-ce que ce jugement va
changer son attitude sa lune de miel
macron toujours là pour le coup je n'en
sais rien tout est possible c'est vrai
qu'on pourrait dire qu après tout ces
amabilités envers un milieu macron la
façon qu'il a eue de ménage emmanuel
macron n'est pas forcément bien
récompensés on ira à la justice est
indépendante et les juges du siège camp
de nicolas sarkozy mais les maquereaux
n'y peut rien certes malgré tout il
semblerait que le parquet ait eu un tout
petit rôle dans cette affaire notamment
le parquet national financiers donc doté
magna convient de changer le patron il
ya peu de temps et c'est ce parquet
national financier car qui avec une
extraordinaire ses vérités au point que
le tribunal était moins sévère que le
parquet national financiers contre
contre nicolas sarkozy donc est ce que
sarkozy se dit finalement j'ai été
roulés dans la farine et maintenant je
veux plus en entendre parler
ou est ce qui se dit mais tu as son nom
plus personne ne peut rien contre les
juges et mâcon pas plus qu'un autre
et donc je l'innocentent dudu du péché
qu'on pourrait lui reprocher et et
finalement je reviens à ma position
initiale qui est de se dire peut-être
qu'une des options qui s'offrent à moi
être 2 et 2 2 ramené à 102 des lecteurs
et à mayol macron franchement je n'en
sais rien je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils le
sachent qu il aime aujourd'hui je vous
disais que vous vouliez vous arrêter à
quelles conséquences pour 2022
à ce jour on regarde 7d
donc ce qui s'est passé hier pour vous
quelles conséquences justement vous
voyez pour pour le prochain alors
écoutez moi je considère qu' il faut
bien considérer que nicolas sarkozy il
ya deux éléments qui jouent pour un
poids politique qui continue d'exister
le premier c'est qu'un fan club nicolas
sarkozy ce fonds de roulement existe
dans le pays
ça représente 2 3 millions de personnes
sans doute profondément choqué par le
jugement prononcé hier et qui vont
considérer donc pour continuer de porter
le soutien à nicolas sarkozy fait partie
de leur rôle et qui donc attendrons ce
que va dire nicolas sarkozy ça comptera
donc beaucoup
deuxième élément de son 3e ligne il a
pas citées prescriptrices voilà et
deuxième chose il a une capacité de
nuisance
nicolas sarkozy et la capacité de
nuisance en politique ça compte du coût
d'où la prudence des guerres des
interventions des différents leaders
il faut à la fois ne pas attaquer la
justice car ce serait ouvrir mal
considéré par beaucoup d'électeurs
surtout extérieur au fan-club de nicolas
sarkozy ce qui est quand même
aujourd'hui l'immense majorité du pays
soyons lucides et en même temps je
dirais dans cette affaire éviter le coup
de patte dévastateur de nicolas sarkozy
contre un candidat potentiel de la
droite car il a une capacité d'exécuter
éventuellement des candidats pas le
niveau par le programme qu'il faut pas
les forces qui rassemble une menace de
victoire de la gauche en va des propos
comme ça et si dans l'interview du
figaro de demain que j'ai encore moins
lui que ni quoi que
alexis brézet mais peut-être peut-être
fois elle se dit je continuerai de
m'exprimer
ça aussi valeur de message pour la
classe politique et en particulier la
classe politique de droite
enfin le dernier point c'est évidemment
leur relation à emmanuel macron je suis
pas sûr pour ma part qu'elles soient
altérées par les juges
car nicolas sarkozy est trop expérimenté
politiquement les juges sont
incontrôlables par le pouvoir politique
et je dirais même
que si le pouvoir politique essaye de
contrôler les juges ça se retourne
absolument contre eux nous sommes très
très loin de la conférence de presse du
31 janvier 1964 du général de gaulle je
dis ça pour les lecteurs les plus
anciens du figaro mais pour tous les
amateurs de l'histoire politique dans
lequel le général de gaulle avait
décrété que tous les pouvoirs était
subordonné à celui du président de la
république y compris l'autorité
judiciaire qu'il n'avait pas qualifié de
pouvoir mais simple autorité de simple
autorité qui était subordonné au pouvoir
donc on voit bien le chemin
invraisemblable pas recouru depuis plus
d'un demi siècle dans les relations
entre la justice et la politique dans la
relation avec emmanuel macron j'ai
tendance donc à considérer que ça
n'oblitère pas les relations mais qu'
évidemment un soutien ou une façon
d'aider emmanuel macron devra se payer
politiquement à nicolas sarkozy et à ses
amis
d'une façon ou d'une autre dans la
perspective de 2022
un rien ne se fera sans rien oui et donc
dans cette perspective évidemment si je
prolonge le raisonnement de rom dans cet
objectif
qu'est-ce qui peut se monnayer pas
qu'une place pour nicolas sarkozy
nicolas sarkozy il va pas ne veut pas
être premier ministre a bien grandi
ministre emmanuel macron la question
n'est pas là la question de manifester
son influence c'est de peser sur le
choix du premier ministre sur le choix
d'un centre de nos vies nice reçoit
décembre d'orientation c'est peut-être
comme ça
si comme vous le dites ce comme le dit
jérôme la relation n'est pas oblitérer
c'est sans doute vrai à ce site
seul après match et quand même la
question que je me pose c'est celle du
parquet jérôme dit très justement que
les juges nous nobis pas n'obéissent
plus certes mais le lien hiérarchique
normalement entre le garde des sceaux et
le parquet ce lien demeure bon il se
trouve qu'aujourd'hui le garde des
sceaux ne parle plus hauts magistrats
parce qu'il est lui-même avocat qu'il
est donc ça que je reconnais que ça qui
est l'institut assure par certains
avouent mais enfin quand on vient de
nommer un patron du parquet pardon je
refasse si on avait voulu obtenir sans
de choses de ce patron du bac et au
moment de le nommer je pense qu'on est
capable de le faire à tout le monde
on s'en est pas donné les moyens
il ya une lecture par certains avocats
justement de cette décision de cette
décision hier justement qui serait aussi
une pierre jetée contre eric eric dupond
moretti
toujours est il que tout dans les dents
les commentaires d'internautes c'est
très frappant à beaucoup d'internautes
critiques s'en prennent au parquet
national financier on espère surtout que
le pnf arrive en fin de carrière ses
juges sont trop à gauche et politisé
nous dit vole pas eu c'est à croire
qu'en politique si tu n'as pas eu
d'ennuis avec la justice et que tu as
raté ta carrière nous dit cet autre
internaute
bref on entend des critiques qui se
multiplient à l'encontre du parquet
national financier est ce que les
français
est ce que l'opinion rejoint ses
critiques jérôme ou est-ce que ça
assouvi ce genre de décisions espèce de
sentiment de vengeance de écouté mon
sens que c'est bien fait c'est à dire
mon expérience de sondeurs qui remonte à
quelques années c'est que dans leur
majorité dans leur grande majorité les
français sont impitoyables avec les
politiques et je dirais même tellement
excessif même parfois dans leur sévérité
que c'est un problème démocratique
nous avons besoin d'une classe politique
respectée honnête nous lui demandons
d'être honnête mais elle doit être aussi
respecté par les citoyens et la chasse
aux politiques quand elle se fait peut
prendre des proportions qui du coup
atteignent la démocratie c'est ce que je
disais c'est à dire qu'au fond tous les
livres de la droite décapité depuis 20
ans la célérité du parquet national
financier pour le groupe dans la sphère
fillon et quelque chose d'ahurissant
d'inimaginable c'est à dire que le
lendemain de l'article de presse du
canard enchaîné on ouvre une information
judiciaire et fillon dans sa naïveté
ignorante est assez étonnante dit il
n'ya qu'une seule hypothèse toujours
attirer ma candidature c'est si je suis
mis en examen que n'at-il dit là il est
mis en examen avec une célérité là aussi
jamais vu après après qu'on a confié
l'instruction de son affaire un juge qui
n'était pas le juge de permanence mais
au juge tournaire qui n'est pas le plus
indulgent des hommes
les autres ont pu le constater du coup
il ya une interférence dans une campagne
présidentielle quelque chose
d'ahurissant quand même là aussi quand
on fait les cantons fera les livres
d'histoire de ces périodes là il ya une
interférence stupéfiante
normalement la justice prend son temps
là par exemple dans cette affaire d'
écoute nous remontons à plusieurs années
donc c'est très différent mais il faut y
ont bien que le fan club de nicolas
sarkozy était curé de la décision
judiciaire
c'est incontestable la droite est choqué
mais les prises aussi à contre pied
parce qu'elle passe son temps à réclamer
une justice plus sévère et on ressort
des tweets de sarkozy expliquant qu' il
fallait pas d'aménagements de peine et
des choses comme ça évidemment c'est le
jeu c'est le jeu quand on est condamné à
plus de six mois pas d'aménagements de
peine et cetera donc on a on a tous ces
éléments là c'est créer une ambiance
délétère tout de même un dans le pays
oui c'est vrai qu'on fera pas pleurer
l'opinion sur le sort des hommes
politiques
il n'en reste pas moins que cette
succession d'affaires peut quand même
faire un peu et vous les regarde moi
j'ai quand même le sentiment quand on
regarde longtemps les réactions
médiatiques politiques générales à la
sphère de sarkozy que beaucoup de gens
qui ne sont pas des qui ne font pas
partie du fan club de sarkozy qui ne
l'ont jamais fait partie du fan club de
feu sarkozy qu'ils soient responsables
publics journée c'est les sondages nous
le dirons assez vite finalement il ya
comme quelque chose de bizarre dans tout
ça c'est vrai que la sphère fillon les
gens bien quelque chose de pas clair en
feutre quatre les chances du roi disons
qu'ils ont quand même de retirer notre
candidate sous le nez en tout cas pour
les gens de droite sont les gens bien se
dit qu'avec quelque chose et là
maintenant
ce couperet qui tombe sur sarkozy avait
quand même des choses étonnantes
les gens sont alors les gens n'entrent
pas dans les dents tous les détails de
la faire enfin des gens bien compris
qu'il y avait dans la procédure des
trucs bizarres qu'on avait mis sur
écoute les avocats qu'on écoutait les
relations entre un avocat et un client
l'a principe comme de justice de
démocratie c'est que les conserves que
les discussions entre un avocat et son
client sont secrètes qu'on avait fait
une enquête parallèle on a mis tout un
tas d'avocats on les avait su que le
complot n'a jamais été vraiment exécuté
et alors là je sais pas si les gens
l'ont senti mais je pense que dans l'est
enfin on va commencer à le voir alors là
je pense que sarkozy va insister là
dessus c'est tellement c'est évident
dans les attendus du jugement
ce quelque chose qui me paraît
absolument une innovation juridique
assez effrayante qui est de dire la
preuve du pacte de corruption dont parle
jérôme ressort d'un fins d'un faisceau
d'indicés graves précis et concordants
résultant des liens d'amitiés nouées
entre les protagonistes
mais donc la preuve c'est un faisceau
d'indicés graves et concordants
autrefois normalement en droite ce qu'on
apprend tous ont droit c'est un faisceau
d'indicés graves et concordants justifie
une mise en examen
non on n'a jamais condamner quelqu'un
sur des indices normalement on les
indices graves et consorts une règle
ajoutant les amitiés dans la série et
qui plus est si ces indices sont
constitués des liens d'amitié entre les
trois personnes disent que les drogues
était l'avocat de sarkozy qui
connaissait asie même si face c'est
quand même assez sidérant en matière de
télé mans preuve que de dire qu'ils
étaient copains c'est un faisceau
d'indicés là dessus je condamne ou veut
il ya plein de gens qui n'ont pas des
grands species de trois sujets je n'aime
pas mais je n'en suis pas un mais qui
disent c'est quand même curieux ce truc
là tels que vous lisez c'est quand même
plus s'il condamnait sur une suspicion
pas plus que sur ses six nations
le débit alors là l'astuce juridique lé
c'est de dire que le délit de corruption
endroit eu l'intention suffit à
caractériser le délit et le le même si
la corruption mais n'a pas été opéré il
peut y avoir un début qu'options mais
encore faut-il trouver cette attention
l'attention c'est en personne c'est ce
qui se passe un peu de temps pour
prouver cette invention fouet un élément
de preuve et donc cet élément de preuve
de l'intention policiers pas trouvé un
fait mais de prouver l'intention c'est
un faisceau d'indicés graves précises et
concordantes
ça fait quand même une espèce de deux
pyramides qui va tenir sur une tête
d'épinglé me permets alexis ça s'appuie
largement sur les écoutes entre un
avocat et son client et là je dirais que
ça inquiète tout citoyen la vérité si
vous avez une affaire judiciaire ça peut
toujours arriver vous discuté au
téléphone avec votre avocat et donc vous
évoquez la meilleure façon d'organiser
votre défense vous êtes dans une fière
ça peut se retourner contre vous par un
système des coûts' et les libertés c'est
les libertés fondamentales
qui sont en cause à ce moment là d'où le
fait que malgré tout il ya dans cette
affaire alors évidemment il ya la
condamnation du personnel politique
était une réaction assez largement
répandue et donc voilà tous pourris le
tous pourris nous guette et et je dirais
que tout de même un ensemble de choses
qui fait qu'on ne voudrais pas être à la
place de ces malheureux justiciables je
n'attendais pas particulièrement le
retour de nicolas sarkozy mis cet
acharnement contre lui me dégoûte nous
dit notamment cet internaute est
effectivement pour reprendre ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure jérôme et laurence
qui nous dit il à un fan club parce
qu'il nous stimule encore lui la
question qu'on vous pose est quand même
ce soir sur twitter c'est pensez vous
que la condamnation de nicolas sarkozy
marque la fin de sa carrière et vous
répondez oui à 52% et 53% tout à l'heure
52 maintenant je leur 3% c'était son
score des victoires en deux sets et
c'est ici nous écoutait elle trouverait
sans doute motif à à se rappeler ce bon
ballon et le 52e et le 52 % c'est la
marque de notre influence dire combien
les modèles qui seront alors c'est pas
un sondage donc on n'est pas encore dans
la marge d'erreur donc ce jeu c'est
juste une question l'autre question
d'avenir ce soir porte sur les manuels
macro et sa gestion actuelle de la crise
sanitaire
alors à ceux qui réclament des
assouplissements le président a fait
hier cette réponse rapportée par la fp
notamment il faut tenir encore quatre à
six semaines alors que faut-il entendre
par quatre à six semaines par cette
réponse eh bien voici je vous propose en
temps dans tous les cas l'explication de
texte du ministre de la santé olivier
ferrand hier soir sur le plateau de
france 2 le président rappelle et il a
totalement raison que hélas sur les
quatre à six prochaines semaines
il faut pas compter qu'on réduisent la
voilure des mesures il faudra le
confinement le couvre-feu pardon et les
mesures actuelles seront un minimum sur
les quatre à six prochaines semaines et
nous espérons évidemment ne pas aller au
delà
à l'échelle du pays et puis nous
espérons évidemment que d'ici quatre à
six semaines on puisse retrouver
davantage de liberté nous l'avons fait
l'année dernière le printemps est moins
propice à la circulation du virus et on
vaccine on protège les plus fragiles
on croise les doigts je vous entends
rire c'est dommage d'attendre juge
entend rire d'un air entendu pendant les
pannes pendant que vous écoutiez encore
verdict ou confinement à la place comme
le vague sentiment qui regrette un peu
et skip moi ce qui me paraît intéressant
d'un point de vue psychologique c'est
que macron et au fond ces deux attitudes
vis-à-vis de la vie vis-à-vis des choses
c'est macron dix bateaux quatre ou six
semaines je pourrai vous on pourra vous
savoir que ça ça va mieux et veyran dit
ce qu'il a dit c'est que d'ici quatre à
six semaines ça n'irait pas mieux c2c de
d2 réalité sont vraies mais macro email
et mis l'accent sur l' après il décède
donner un débouché et et veyran il à
dire toujours
il essaie on sent bien depuis depuis
plusieurs semaines et du même depuis
plusieurs mois que de danser au sommet
de l'état il ya deux lignes qui sont
souvent dit elle-même fonctionnelle
entre d'un côté vers ans les grands
pontes de la santé le comité de
l'hérault de ces autorités compagnie et
pendant longtemps castex et d'autres qui
le sont pour fermer prendre des
précautions et de l'autre côté macro qui
depuis le début et pour essayer le plus
possible de libérer les choses et de ne
pas mettre de 2,2 à mettre tout le pays
à la grèce si on peut les si on peut
l'éviter
macron a pris un pari qu'à l'époque nous
fierons n'avait soutenu et de ce qui
nous arrive de le critiquer aussi pour
bien d'autres raisons et bien et je sais
que dans cette affaire de decaux vide
entre les vaccins les tests les masques
les tout ce qu'on veut il ya plein de
choses critiquable mais on l'avait
soutenu sur cette idée qu'il ya trois
semaines de dire ne re confie n'ont pas
trop tôt ça ne sert à rien attendant que
ça aille mal pour confiner à l'époque ça
avait été très critiqué y compris par
monsieur vérone mezza voce par monsieur
castex par tout un tas de médecins il
semblerait pour l'instant alors on
croise les doigts mais pour l'instant
que le choix est soit validée par la
réalité les choses de ne pas absolument
dérapé et si dans telle ou telle région
ça va un peu moins bien ici on prend des
mesures en termes de régions je pense
que aujourd'hui la réalité peut-être que
demain il en ira autrement valide plutôt
le le ce risque ce pari qu'avait pris
macron est-ce que c'est validé par la
réalité semble-t-il
est-ce que c'est validé par l'opinion
géraud masqué
et on peut aller plus loin à ce que
l'assouplissement dans quatre à six
semaines c'est un bon calcul vis-à-vis
de l'opinion
écoutez tout le pari politique d'
emmanuel macron tout il y met j'irai
tout son poids politique et sera des
conséquences sur la suite
c'est d'éviter de re confinement
généralisée du pays ça c'est la
condition absolue pour lui d'être en
cohérence avec le choix qu'il a fait de
refuser leur confinement préventif qu'on
lui propose effectivement et derrière de
dire on a juste au mieux au mieux dans
une période extrêmement difficile mais
en évitant de martyriser les français
davantage dans ce qu'ils ont vécu jusque
là si durement et il faut à la fois
éviter ce confinement généralisée et
éviter d'être dans situation
catastrophique dans les hôpitaux c'est à
dire la situation tous les chefs de
service arrive dans le 20 heures et dix
c'est la catastrophe on donne à
montpellier ils auront plus de place
nous allons devoir faire le tri des
malades
nous allons devoir soigner les malades a
dans les ambulances qui sont dans la
cour de l'hôpital
c'est des images qu'on a vu par exemple
sur l'italie et qui serait
catastrophique donc c'est je dirais le
petit couloir qu'empruntent macron et
donc c'est la politique de
territorialiser comme on dit pour
prendre des décisions qui suppose une
bonne coordination avec les élus et la
la politique parfois sourit quand même
ça arrive aux gouvernants sert à un nid
d'algos a rendu un éminent service à
emmanuel macron d'abord en proposant le
confinement trois semaines de paris via
son premier adjoint à la semaine
dernière qui paraissait quelque chose
d'ahurissant parce que paris tout seul
pour finn et trois semaines s'est imposé
au parisien quelque chose de terrible
pour ne servir à peu près à rien et là
jean castex qui fête commence à faire un
tout petit peu de politique a eu le mot
cruel de fadaises pour des et alors
maintenant qu'après avoir proposé des
trois semaines de confinement de paris
le confinement du week-end pour la
région parisienne ce serait quelque
chose d'inhumain nous a expliqué anne
hidalgo
ce qui fait je dois dire que comme on
n'arrive pas toujours à une bonne
entente avec les élus quand les élus
vous servent comme ça sur un plateau les
décisions que vous devrez prendre c'est
évidemment
inespéré pour le pouvoir alors il reste
que quand même la musique d'une petite
musique qui monte c'est que la situation
se tend dans les hôpitaux
d'ile-de-france qu'on évoque la rumeur
d'un confinement
le week end des samedi
d'ailleurs alexis est-ce qu'il faut il
voir pareille manoeuvre du parti confie
le confirme ce que vous direz certes
certains intervenants ici ici ou bien
s'il ya un risque réel franchement si on
regarde les chiffres on voit que les
unes pied une grogne sur un plateau qui
était un tout petit peu à la hausse
depuis 15 jours et qui est depuis trois
jours et transforme un tout petit peu à
la baisse est très probablement lié aux
évolutions dues aux évolutions du climat
il n'y a pas d'évolution dramatique en
tout cas pas en ile de france peut-être
dans l'est et un peu plus compliqué mais
enfin encore mais il ya aujourd'hui pas
de situation devant la presse il y en a
mais il faudra prendre des mesures et
puis moi c'est pas plus compliqué que ça
fasse un peu compliqué c'est
l'exposition qui consiste à dire je
redis ce qu'a dit jérôme sa carrière de
courir au devant des mesures
contraignantes attendant que les choses
se passent pour pour prendre les mesures
qui s'imposent et quand même dû me
semble-t-il me semble-t-il du bon sens
et non paris à moi c'est que plus toute
chose à et en ligue 2 tout son beauty
look lima vu qu'ils savent que tu fais
et c'est le pari je crois de maquereaux
c'est de se dire que lhasa s'adoucit et
on va aller vers les beaux jours et si
tout va bien on recourt au queen un tout
petit peu dans telle ville dans un petit
couvre-feu ici là on va arriver jusqu'au
printemps de france c'est quand même 12
millions d'habitants donc c'est pas un
confinement d'île de france le week-end
ce n'est quand même pas une petite
terrasse du tout que ça n'est pas la
même chose que dunkerque et nice ça sac
pèse politiquement nationalement très
lourdement
et si en plus nous sommes déjà dans les
beaux jours sans avoir encore les
températures tout à fait ses beaux jours
c'est à dire sans que la menace du virus
se réduisent on est dans une situation
où ce sera difficile à faire accepter
dans toute l'ile-de-france et à faire
respecter
là il ya un enjeu est difficile ce qui
est intéressant c'est que vous parlez
des dalles goût de vous parler des
gautherets justement mais on pourrait
parler aussi de valérie pécresse qui a
surenchéri quand on en a parlé d'un
cofinancement de paris grâce à des
hommes il faut pas confier que paris
considère tout et on prend avec eux
et où ciotti qui parle de co2 de 2,0
coville etc
on sent qu'à ce moment de deux
responsables politiques d'abord l'idée
de se dire qu'il faut il vaut mieux trop
de précautions que pas assez
d'une part d'autre part qu'il faut
écouter les électeurs et que assemble
des électeurs notamment les plus âgés
sont très demandeurs de de précaution et
de sueur précaution et qu'il faut les
différentes
et puis sans doute aussi se sont-ils dit
au fond macro a pris un risque
il a il a il a refusé de confiner mais
c'est un tour normal si on reconfirmer
vaut mieux être le premier mardi qu'il
fallait être confinés comme ça on aura
encore un coup d'avancé on pourra dire
alors vous l'avait bien dit bon coup à
faire beaucoup
les légumes ont l'air de rebaisser les
mêmes qui nous disait qu'il faut les
reprendre des précautions
j'ai le sentiment que dans les semaines
qui viennent on va les revoir repartir
dans l'autre sens en réclamant les
réouvertures qui a vécu en voilà oui
franchement moi je serai l'opposition
plutôt qu'une base sur l'histoire de
confinement il ya des choses sur
lesquelles on peut se battre et qui se
la sont vraies en tout état de cause
notamment la progression de la
vaccination
ça c'est quelque chose qui si on
s'intéresse à l'aspect électoral des
choses plaît aux seniors en disant il
faut les vexer parce qu'aujourd'hui ce
qui préoccupe les gens et les gens ont
la partie de la pollution sait où est ce
que je vais trouver mon ex donc ça c'est
un vrai cheval de bataille c'est un
cheval de bataille légitime et serre
permet de dire en même temps le jour où
il y aura un maximum de gens vaccinés
notamment chez les seniors les jeunes
pourront sortir on fermera pas le pays
donc c'est un moyen de réconcilier les
français
la vaccination les lits d'hôpitaux me
paraissent des chevaux de bataille
politiquement plus opportun que de se
bagarrer un jour pour refermer un jour
pour ouvrir un jour pour fermer un jour
pour ouvrir pour dire le contraire
macron sans fin de l'étape suivante pour
emmanuel macron l'étape décisive quand
les seniors seront suffisamment vacciner
c'est de donner corps plus sérieusement
à tester alerté protéger c'est à dire
quand d'autres termes le grand débat à
venir qui devrait intéresser j'imagine
le figaro hausse très sérieusement c'est
les libertés est-ce qu'il faut pas
empiéter sur un certain nombre de
libertés pour assurer un tracé qui soit
beaucoup plus vigoureux c'est le
problème du qr code quand vous rentrez
dans un restaurant qui fait que c'est le
test salivaire éventuellement que vous
devez faire si vous ne pouvez pas
montrer
vous êtes déjà vaccine
est ce qu'on rend obligatoire ce genre
de choses dans les protocoles et ça je
dirais même qu'on peut pas décider tout
seul il faut un débat public très large
là dessus est ce que le pays considère
que ça peut se faire ça doit se faire
arriver à cette étape du coc vite parce
que sinon comme les jeunes vont pas
pouvoir se faire vacciner avant six ou
sept mois dans les délais que nous avons
on va pas avoir des vieux qui peuvent
aller au restaurant très tranquillement
et des jeunes qui sont interdits de
sortie ça c'est pas possible donc il va
falloir trouver cette voix qui s est un
des grands débats
est-ce que les libertés est ce qu'il
faut un certain jean nombre de libertés
individuelles peuvent être modifiés dans
la période à venir
justin vernon peut-être plusieurs
politologues pointer un indicateur qui
est sous-estimé qui masque et peut-être
par la lassitude et la résignation sont
des sentiments développer dans l'opinion
c'est la colère en particulier justement
vous dit vous l'avez vous avez vous
évoqué cette catégorie est celle et chez
les retraités
est-ce que vous avez perçu de la même
chose écoutez il faut bien dire que
derrière ce qui caractérise la période
moi je dirais c'est plutôt le mot
magique ses distances yale la distance
distant ciel de tout et c'est une
société où le distance yale qui est donc
la façon dont on suit de l'extérieur sur
son ordinateur les choses on n'a pas le
droit de sortir que les étudiants
doivent ne se rencontre plus vous rendez
compte pour des étudiants ne plus
rencontrer la situation donc on a ça et
puis la vaccination alexis le soulignait
ça c'est quelque chose qui choque
on a fait prendre rendez vous aux gens
on les a fait prendre des rendez vous on
ne les respecte pas ces rendez vous
alors ils ont bon dos nous apprenons à
réalité qui a des centaines de milliers
de doses inutilisées qui n'arrivent pas
aux gens alors ça c'est là par exemple
on ouvre nous restons sur emmanuel
macron c'est là où on attend qu'il
bouscule et administratifs
dansez dansez incapacité il ya une
attente d'efficacité ça c'est pas 2 de
la science les gens comprennent qu'on
peut pas maîtriser les greens une
épidémie qu'on sait pas très bien ce qui
se passe quand on se voit très bien pour
ça monte ça bet.e ouvrir fermer tout ça
les gens comprennent qu'il
ne savent pas trop ce qu'il faut faire
mais en revanche distribuer des doses de
vaccin tous sont disponibles qui sont
disponibles tout le monde se dit bon
face à ces deux c'est une simple
question de gestion d'efficacité
quittant plus la promesse des manières
un comble qu'il est absolument important
que la macro maintenant yariv alors on
autorise d'astrazeneca il était
peut-être temps maintenant le problème
c'est qu'on a tellement dit on a fait
campagne contre ces quinze années quoi
pendant dix semaines
alors maintenant on est en train de dire
à prôner de l'asra zeneca mêlée puis les
personnes âgées disent mais
attendez-vous nous a expliqué il ya
trois jours qu'il fallait pas en prendre
pour vous
enfin les pharmaciens à administrer les
vaccins enfin bon on est en train un peu
de bouger les choses mais à deux à
l'heure donc à par rapport à la promesse
qui celle d'eminem mâcon d'efficacité de
performance de 2 2 on va délivrer dans
une touffe au gabut l'air de management
on va délivrer on va donner les
solutions on va ben j'en dise oui le
résultat est là il faut qu'il fasse
attention parce que c'est effectivement
les retraités que ça touche qui eux sont
toute la journée sur leurs douze
ordinateurs a essayé de prendre des
rendez-vous qu'on leur donne jamais et
c'est quand même c'est aujourd'hui des
bataillons qui qui seront décisifs dans
la bataille présidentielle qui s'annonce
il s'agit pas de les perdre déjà les
jupes des jeunes sont très énervé d'être
enfermé mais si en plus les les vieux
soient énervés de pas avoir de vacances
à faire beaucoup de gens mécontents et
ça c'est raconter dans le figaro en tout
cas à lire demain dans l'édition papier
et qui est bien sûr disponible sur le
site dans les prochaines heures tout
comme l'interview de nicolas sarkozy et
les coulisses d'ailleurs du
rétropédalage d'anne hidalgo ou bien
encore emmanuel macron face à
l'administration sas est à retrouver sur
figaro vox la question qui était posée
était posée en ce moment d'ailleurs sur
le site du figaro c est ce que vous êtes
prêts à vous faire vacciner avec
astrazeneca et au dernier pointage ses
58 % iront à pose également la question
sur twitter où là c'est un petit peu un
peu moins 54 % mais sur le site ses 58 %
en 2000 quand deux oui pouvez continuer
à voter
vous pouvez continuer à voter merci
beaucoup merci je remercie alexis et on
se retrouve demain même heure même
endroit avec guillaume roquette a très
vite sur figure live
[Musique]